Las papilas gustativas constan de neuronas especializadas,
o receptores del gusto.
Cuando comemos algo que despierta cierto gusto,
las neuronas mandan una señal al cerebro,
permitiéndole saber qué es dulce y qué es amargo.
Así que cuando una mosca come una banana,
se activan sus neuronas del sabor dulce.
Pero cuando come brócoli, esas neuronas quedan inactivas.
¿Qué pasaría si pudiéramos forzar la activación de las neuronas del sabor dulce
cada vez que la mosca come brócoli?
Quizás a la mosca le pueda gustar el brócoli tanto como la banana.
Entra la optogenética.
Es la nueva herramienta revolucionaria que está cautivando a la neurociencia.
En este caso, "opto" significa "luz",
y "genética" significa que estas moscas se han modificado
con un gen especial que hace que solo ciertas neuronas respondan a la luz.
En nuestro caso, agregamos el gen especial a los receptores del sabor dulce.
Ahora, lo divertido.
La optogenética significa que podemos controlar las neuronas especiales
cuando estén expuestas a una luz brillante,
haciendo que transmitan mensajes al cerebro.
En este experimento,
estas moscas modificadas tendrán que elegir otra vez
entre la banana y el brócoli,
pero ahora, cada vez que la mosca come brócoli,
se encenderá una luz roja grande y brillante.
Cuando los canales vean esa luz roja, se abrirán y activarán esa neurona,
y la señal del sabor dulce se transmitirá al cerebro.
¿Cómo se sacan las moscas?
SB: Usamos un aspirador bucal...
dos pajitas conectadas.
GG: ...un nombre sofisticado para una pajita.
SB: Básicamente.
GG: Las vas a sorber por la pajita.
SB: Sí.
GG: ¿Has sorbido una a la boca alguna vez?
SB: Una o dos veces.
GG: Ya. Sacaste las cuatro. Perfecto.
Enciendes los optoestimuladores,
y colocas la luz justo encima de los compartimentos.
Ahora esperamos hasta que coman el brócoli
y, cuando la luz se active,
pensarán que ese sabor es dulce.
¡Ven! Se está acercando...
¡Vamos! ¡Sabe rico!
SB: Está por comerlo.
GG: ¡Ha vuelto! ¡Estupendo!
Bien. Ahora vemos que algunas de estas moscas están cambiando
la banana por el brócoli.
SB: Exacto, sí.
GG: Entonces, cada vez que se apaga esta luz,
significa que piensan que saborean algo dulce.
SB: Sí. A este le gusta bastante.
GG: Vimos que pudimos rescatar el brócoli
y hacerlo tan apetitoso como la banana a nuestras moscas de la fruta.
Y pudimos replicar estos mismos resultados
en todos nuestros experimentos.
La pregunta es: ¿Podemos hacer lo mismo con los humanos?
Bueno, eso depende de unas cuantas cosas.
Primero, si las herramientas optogenéticas funcionan en humanos.
Parece que la respuesta es sí,
y, de hecho, ya se están planeando ensayos clínicos
que tratarán el dolor crónico y la ceguera mediante optogenética.
La próxima pregunta es: ¿podemos activar una luz fácilmente
para que se encienda cada vez que comamos verduras?
Para eso, temo que, al menos por el momento,
la respuesta todavía es no.
Pero hoy, pudimos saborear un poquito de la optogenética
y sus magníficas posibilidades.
(Música)